what's going on guys national master
james cantor third here with chess.com
and today we have game of the day
with the white pieces we have ariana
tari and with the black pieces we have
magnus
carlsen let's get right into it guys
here we go e4 and c5
a sicilian let's see which one knight of
three at knight to c6
d4 and c takes d4 now after c takes d4
there is knight takes d4 and knight f6
here
looking like it's going to be a special
cough like magnus played against fabiano
carowanna
in the world championship so after
knight f6 there is knight to c3 and
instead of the shreznikov that he
probably is prepared for
he plays d6 which is very very flexible
here so let's see how he proceeds
after bishop to g5 which is a very
aggressive move here
just stating that hey i'm going to
attack you maybe play stuff like f4
maybe even castle queen side and launch
an attack now after bishop to g5 there's
bishop to d7
just wanting to bring our rook to the
file and also developing as well
after bishop d7 there is queen to d2 as
it looks like he's gonna go for this
immediate capsule queen side and just
launch my pawns at you
and after queen to d2 there's a6
preparing b5
and stopping anything from white coming
to the b5 square
as well after a6 there is castle's queen
side and we do have
e6 here guys nothing else but e6 very
flexible
take notes here you want to have
flexibility and you want to have options
in your game here
e6 is not telling anything it's only
saying that we're going to put our
bishop here on e7
but we don't know if we're going to play
d5 later if we're going to play e5
if we're going to push any of these at
all maybe at the right moment maybe
we'll be able to push these but this is
a very flexible um
opening now at the same time you do have
less space and when you have less space
you will be more cramped so let's see
what happens after e6 f4 by
white here by ariana and just playing
aggressive e5 could be a thing
eventually
luckily that b5 square is covered by us
because
things like bishop to b5 or even
capturing and playing e5 could be
annoying sometimes
so after f4 we have bishop to e7 getting
our pieces off of the back rank
and blocking this file at the same time
or diagonal
we have knight to f3 very interesting
move by ariane guys if you have more
space you want to do less trades and if
you have less
less space you want to do more trades so
knight f3 is a very common move in these
type of positions just keeping the space
we don't want to trade and if we do
capture then we could take with the
bishop and e4 is
attacked rook to c8 still coming and
actually black's doing just fine here
now after knight f3
black's like let's go for it it's that
time b5 let's go
now our king is still in the center here
we haven't committed to the king side
but we are starting our attack already
in like night or fashion
so for all the night or fans out there
this is very very similar in your type
of play with a b5
and maybe even bringing the queen over
to a6 to a5 or b6
and something something to do with the
knight maybe knight to b4 in some cases
and rook to ca
and just start this queen side attack
out of nowhere after bishop to f6
which is a very interesting move here
honestly you do have to do something
with his bishop h6 is coming
and if you just back up you could but
that's just not what we wanted to do
so after bishop takes f6 guys g takes f6
so you don't lose the pawn on
d6 d6 is absolutely hanging so he takes
with the pawn here
stay uh stop and take a look at this
position
just just look at it what is going on
here how do you feel about this
and how do you feel about white's
position here guys this is very very
advanced chess as these are both
very strong grand masters now check this
out guys in
this kind of structure here black is
doing just fine but he is definitely
defending he's trying to figure out what
he wants to do here and he's going to
adapt over white
of what white does so let's see what
happens after g takes f6 there's king to
b1
king to b1 is always a good move they
always say always play king b1 or king
b8 if you capture queenside and you
haven't put your king on the b file yet
you usually aren't fully castled yet
because things like rook to c8 is
extremely annoying and
vice versa if you're playing black and
there's a rook on b1 eyeing the king
that may be on uh the c file actually
not the b file you want to put the king
on the b
file as quickly as possible after you
cast the queenside queen to b6 he gets
the queen out of the way is he preparing
the
castle queenside well let's see after f5
which is a very strong move here
just saying hey i'm going to break some
stuff up maybe g4 is coming
and we're just going to attack you as
much as we can now black's doing just
fine here but it does
take precision and accuracy now after f5
there is a capsule queen side here guys
how many of you would have castled
kingside that would have been extremely
bad here after queen h6 is almost
almost just destroying and then after
follow like rook to d3 and rook to g3
with the king on g8
this is already lights out have a good
day right so after f5 he castle queen
side which is very interesting you see
these kind of open dynamic
castle queen side in an open kind of
position with a messed up pawn structure
kind of position
in semi-slots so if you play the simi
slot
sometimes even the slop you have a
similar position like this where it gets
extremely sharp after capsule queen side
we do have bishop to d3 guys you gotta
develop your pieces
no matter what and then we have king to
b8 as we see
they both put your kings on the b file
guys i mean when you you can't fully
castle until you put your king on the b
file when you castle a queen side now
after king to ba there's knight to e2
just a little bit of rearranging
and making sure our pieces are better
once you develop your pieces you need to
go back
and then you have to figure out what is
the best place for my pieces
so if you look at this knight it
literally had no squares to go to
so he's just going to reroute it to a
better side of the board or even
somewhere where he can be
active now we have bishop ca very nice
move he's doing the same thing
this bishop was very very bad it's not
doing anything it's actually blocking
this file as well
so he's just gonna move it out of the
way maybe we'll put it here maybe we'll
move it back let's see
so then he plays knight to f4 aryan is
actually just going to reroute the
knight just like we saw here he moved it
to e2
and now to f4 just to put a little bit
of pressure on the center here and then
knight to e5 by magnus i really like
this move here
just opening up the game we do have less
space so what do you look for guys
trades and especially in the sicilians
guys sicilians are very very nice
for black when we do get trades and go
into end games where we could be
slightly better
due to our position and pawn structures
bishop to e2 for aryan
and then an interesting move here from
black guys if you look at this position
there's a there's a lot of dynamicism to
it what would you actually play in this
position
here we go black shows d5 i like d5 here
it's a very very strong move guys is
breaking up the center
breaking up the center the rooks are uh
connected here they're defended so
after e takes d5 we take the pawn
the other way we don't even take on d5
are you serious what is this it's triple
pawns this is the world champion with
three triple pawns on the f file
this is insane what do you mean why
would you even take this way
after i looked at this game this was
very very very very interesting i like
this a lot because he
voluntarily he voluntarily tripled his
pawns here on the f file
knight to d4 it seems like black is like
in trouble is what it feels like here i
mean there's holes in the position
but we have two bishops that are sharp
and two bishops are an advantage here
but we do have triple pawns guys insane
triple pawns
so let's see what he does about it he
plays bishop c5 he gets a little bit
aggressive here
let's see what's going to happen it's
going to get really crazy in a second
rook 8 still f1 rook h2e8 here getting
our last piece into the game
and then after a3 now this one is is
hard this is a hard move to make
guys what would you play here what would
you play with magnus carlsen
as black what would you play after a3
he made a waiting move which was really
cool king 2a
maybe even some prophylaxis there maybe
if he wants to move the knight and
stopping any checks that may be able to
get here eventually but he played king
to a8 more of like a waiting move but
also prophylaxis maybe even putting a
rook on the b
file eventually let's see what happens
king a8 and h3 interesting move maybe
just trying to play g4
just trying to do something at the end
of the day we do have to make a move
here and after bishop to d7 he moves it
back looks like we're preparing rook to
b8
the knight to h5 he's like okay time to
attack f6
is not hanging because it is defended
but f5 is hanging and this
is triple pawns guys we got triple pawns
this isn't that fun
the knight to c4 you have to play
aggressive if you look at the night or
type positions
you will always see this 95 knight to c4
queens on b6 or c7 and a rook coming to
the final
aiming at this side of the board it's an
all out king hunt
knight to c4 bishop takes c4 b takes c4
and then queen to c3
let's see let's take a look of inventory
here what's going on we have two bishops
for black we have triple pawns on the
file
and the knight is two nights for the one
or two two nights for white
and um and two rooks and a queen so
after queen to c3 we have rook to b8
hitting the b2 pawn so the queen's kind
of trapped not really not trapped but he
can't move from c4 or c3 if you take on
c4 there's checkmate on b2
so let's actually see what he does to
untangle he plays rook 2f3 here
and now guys this is a very highlight
moment this is a big boy move
hopefully you did your tactics today if
you have and if you haven't then this is
the time
black to move guys what would you play
magnus carlsen lifted his piece and
played
what in this position if you said
rook to e1 oh my goodness wow what is on
the board
rook to e1 can you even do that is that
even legal rook to e1 look at this move
guys
if queen takes e1 self-explanatory queen
takes b2
that's already done have a nice day so
he takes with the rook because it's
forced there's nothing really else to do
after rook takes e1
bishop takes d4 wow look at the pressure
on the b
two pawn this was a beautiful move here
guys rook to e1 make sure you do your
tactics and look for the moves that you
don't think are possible
and he found it rookie one and bishop
takes d4 and then we have queen to b4
just blocking the file
you have to do something because this is
going to get very scary then he moves
his queen to c7 and again guys we have
triple pawns here but what a decisive
attack here
amazing how he moved his king to aa put
the rook on ba
open the file by playing knight to c4
and use every single piece to attack the
king
a beautiful display a master at work
here or grand master
at work world champion at work queen to
c7 and d6
you take my queen i take yours but i'll
be winning so let's play queen to c6 and
get out of the way
after queen to a5 here bishop to b
bishop takes b2
it's going to get very crazy here let's
see what happens in the next few moves
king to a2 and bishop to e5 as rook to
b2 is definitely on the way
so he plays rook to b1 and says not
today rook takes
king takes and then queen takes d6 take
a quick inventory we're down in exchange
here with black but we have bishops and
a weak king here
with may threats literally everywhere on
the board literally everywhere so
all kind of things are happening i mean
even queen of b8 could be very scary as
well
so king to c1 he gets out of the way and
then we have queen d4 centralized the
queen
there's a check here there's a check
here there's a check everywhere he
voluntarily gives up the pawn and says
hey
well you don't have any other checks you
can't play rook to b3 that would be
disastrous but he can't play it and you
can't just do it with your queen you
don't even have a check
you don't have a check wow just gave up
the pawn to get more initiative here
and then c3 by white and here we go guys
watch
the precision queen g1 king d2
queen takes g2 your rooks hanging king
to e3 now it's defended
f4 use every piece we have on the board
and after knight takes
bishop takes rook takes hey we're out of
the woods here we're feeling great we
got that exchange we're still up this
exchange
or are we up
the exchange anymore he gets it right
back here
beautiful beautiful way a display of
moves here as he's able
to come back here check queenie one best
move here because queen e5 is made if
you go king f4 i mean beautiful
geometry of the squares here queen e5
king takes c4
queen e4 check king to c5 i take the
rook
and now you're down a piece not it up in
exchange anymore
not enough checks here for a perpetual
we can always just black
block as well um but maybe yeah we could
block
maybe we could block but if czech king
here is probably the best to be honest
and after king to d6 we have bishop to
c8 and then aryan
resigned right in this position guys
there's really nothing you can do after
queen here
queen to be a b6 we just come back and
block and honestly we're fine and we're
winning we're up
material here and this game is going to
be over very soon so ariane resigned
right here in this position
what a game here guys this was amazing
display of just sit back and wait
and then start to attack adapt over your
opponent's position
and adapt to what they do and find the
best moves like rookie one
the ones that you didn't even think
about and this was a beautiful display
by magnus carlson i am national master
james canty iii and this was game of the
day and i'll see you guys on the next
video